(mouse clicking)
(computer chiming)
(pensive synthesizer and percussion music)
- Welcome, we are very
glad to see you here today.
I'm Nick Spitzer, Co-Director
of the Kavli Institute
for Brain and Mind, here in La Jolla,
and we have a wonderful
program this afternoon.
We're very happy that you're
here to take it all in.
I want to say a few words
about the Kavli Institute for
Brain and Mind as we start.
In the little over a decade
that we've been in business,
we have been trying to bridge
across different disciplines
associated with understanding the brain.
And so, as you can see,
here, we are trying
to bring together people
interested in cognitive science,
psychology, on the one hand,
with neuroscientists and
neurologists, on the other hand,
to bridge what has often
been a set of silos
separating the people,
of course all concerned
with the same subject
and Rusty Gage, Fred Gage, here, joins me
as Co-Director of the KIBM;
Ralph Greenspan is our Associate Director.
Since the announcement
of the BRAIN Initiative
in April 2013, the KIBM
has launched a series
of further initiatives,
which are illustrated here,
beginning with the Center
for Brain Activity Mapping.
One of the big threads of
the BRAIN Initiative is
to develop new technologies
with which to map the
connections within the brain
and this has been the focus
of the Center for Brain Activity Mapping.
In addition, Ralph Greenspan
has reached North to Sacramento
to the Legislature there
and achieved funding
in the State Budget of
the State of California
for Cal-BRAIN, again, a
neurotechnology program
for the, now, entire state of California.
Most recently, the San
Diego Brain Consortium,
here in San Diego, has worked
to bring together people
from across the San Diego region
to work on understanding the
brain with new technology.
In each of these cases,
the goals are achieved
by providing grants to
bring together people
and motivate them to
work on these projects.
The whole process is made
possible by The Kavli Foundation
to which we are very grateful.
They, as many of you will
know, have been instrumental
in pushing forward scientific
research in a number of fields
noted here in addition to neuroscience.
I should add that they also
fund some very exciting prizes
every other year and we're very pleased
that one of the Co-Chairs
of the Symposium today
is Carla Shatz who was a winner
of the Kavli Prize in
Neuroscience earlier this year.
Bob Conn, Robert Conn, formerly
a Professor and Dean here
at the University of
California San Diego, is now
President of the Kavli Foundation,
Miyoung Chun is the
Executive Vice President
for Scientific Programs and,
together, the two of them
have done a great deal to push
forward scientific research
across a wide range of disciplines.
I want to add that the
structure of this symposium is
based on a series of symposia
that have been going on for a long time.
This afternoon, we are here together
for the inaugural Kavli
Symposium presented by the KIBM,
but the CARTA Symposia,
which I know are familiar
to a number of you,
have really been a wonderful model
for what we are doing here together today
and they are focused on answering
some of the big questions
about human beings:
Where did we come from?
How did we get here?
Ajit Varki, Fred Gage,
Margaret Schoeninger
and Pascal Gagneux run these symposia
and we're very happy to acknowledge
their participation in helping
us with our inaugural event.
This brings us, then, to
the program for today,
the influence of early experience
on the organization and
function of the adult brain.
This is a subject that's of great interest
to everyone in the audience
and maybe there'll be
some reflection back on our
origins at earlier times.
There was a point early in my career
in which we thought that the
brain could be understood
either as some aspects
regulated by genes and genetic programs,
whereas other aspects of
the brain's operation were
regulated by activity,
electrical activity,
and, now, we appreciate and I think
this will be richly illustrated today,
that genes and activity
are very much partners
with one another.
Nature and nurture are, in
fact, combined in these studies.
So, here will be some of the questions
that we will be addressing
during the course of the afternoon.
How do the events of
early development show up?
What are the risks and
opportunities of early development
and their consequences for adult behavior?
And, finally, does identification
of some critical windows
at early stages of development
provide opportunities
for us to reopen those windows
at a later stage in life?
So, with that, I'll
turn the microphone over
to Terry Sejnowski who will
give us a brief introduction
for the opening of the afternoon.
- We have a great group
here, today, of speakers
and a wonderful audience, so
I'm really looking forward
to all the talks.
I want to, first of all, welcome you
on behalf of the Salk Institute,
Rusty Gage, my colleague who
is a Co-Director of KIBM,
and I'm also on the
faculty here and at UCSD.
So, one of the great privileges
of being here at the Salk
was the beginning to know Francis Crick
and Francis told me this story, once,
and I think it might be a
good way to get the Symposium
off to, on the right foot.
He was giving a talk to a lay audience
and the question period came up
and one of the ladies in the
front row put her hand up
and said, "Professor
Crick, could you tell me,
"what's the most exciting thing,
"discovery that's been
made in neuroscience?"
And, Francis thought
for a moment and said,
"Well, I think the most exciting
thing that I can think of
"is that neuroscience has discovered
"that the brain is plastic,"
and she fainted straight away
(audience laughing)
and that's really a, that's
really the crucial mechanism
for learning and memory is the
fact that the brain really is
responsive to things, experiences you have
and, as you'll see, not
just during the day,
but also at night.
Now, we've picked speakers
to give you a broad spectrum,
all the way from the
molecules up to, you know,
the whole coordinated
central nervous system
that is responsible for
all the behaviors you have,
all the thoughts that you have
and the, you know, your
hopes and aspirations
and that's really,
again, what Francis was,
tried to get across in his book,
The Astonishing Hypothesis.
Another incident,
this is Ramachandran, who is
a colleague at, now, at UCSD
and is also a very, very
prominent neuroscientist,
once got a call from Francis.
Francis was writing his
book and Francis says this,
"Rama, I have just gotten
back from my editor,
"you know, marked up first chapters
"and she said that I ought to
give it to a layman to read
"and get a feedback from a layman.
"Do you know any laymen?"
(audience laughing)
So, we're going to make an effort to try
to make our, the science
as accessible as possible.
(pensive synthesizer and percussion music)